ils sont en colère et on les entend
maintenant presque partout les pêcheurs
amplifie donc leur mouvement de
protestation contre la hausse du gazole
qui a atteint un nouveau record
aujourd'hui les blocages ses tantes je
vous le disais à la méditerranée à
presque toute la façade atlantique
valérie le rouge françoise maso
la mer est agitée ce matin à dieppe un
peu comme les esprits les marins
bloquent l'accès au port et la sortie
des ferries
personne xan personne fort que ça va
durer un juif au pas vous dire autre
action dans l'hérault cette fois les
pêcheurs barre l'entrée du dépôt de
carburant de frontignan à saint malo au
boulogne-sur-mer ils ont opté pour la
grève le mouvement est parti des sables
d'olonne il ya huit jours avant de
s'étendre aux autres ports de
l'atlantique depuis ce matin ils
touchent le pas de calais la normandie
la bretagne mais aussi la méditerranée
les pêcheurs protestent contre un gazole
trop cher 74 centimes le litre
aujourd'hui contre 55 au début de
l'année pour certains mieux vaut rester
au port je connais pour une personne qui
peut travailler pendant vingt-quatre
joueurs dans son moi et pas touché un
centime pour un plan daide a pourtant
été mise en place en janvier 310
millions d'euros sur trois ans mais pas
de quoi compenser la hausse du gazole
les pêcheurs exige un nouveau coup de
pouce du gouvernement
on attend le ministre mercredi ce qui va
nous dire dont il apprend le choix faire
rire et laisse le droit d'aller pêcher
et puis qu'ils nous fassent quelque
chose pour le gazole on peut pas les
meilleures conditions là à la différence
des routiers les pêcheurs ne peuvent pas
répercuter l'augmentation du carburant
sur leurs prix de vente car le poisson
est vendu aux enchères à la criée ils
réclament donc un tarif minimum et
poisson ou un prix fixe du gazole à 30
centimes le litre contre le double
aujourd'hui